so you've proposed your energy price
plan you now want parliament recalled
but we have in the past weeks heard from
the liberal democrats the snp and gordon
brown
wanting parliament to be recalled are
you a bit late to this
no i mean i think the most important
thing is that households are worrying
now and because the off gem um price
rise is due to be announced in seven
days time
um the government has failed to come up
with their own plan and we announced our
plan which is now fully you know it's
fully costed we know where we're going
to get the money we're going to take the
money from those big oil and gas
producers who have so benefited from the
windfall in um oil and gas prices and we
need to get back to parliament on monday
so that we can legislate before the
off-gem price rise the time to act is
now the government has failed they could
have acted weeks ago they could have
acted months ago in fact when labour
first called for a windfall tax on oil
and gas way back in january
that is why under our plan we would back
date that when full tax and close the
loophole that the government put in
their energy price levy we would
backdate it all the way back to january
because nobody can say that we haven't
worn the oil and gas companies that
their massive profits at a time of
national crisis with inflation
skyrocketing skyrocketing have to be
used to help households through this
very difficult time
but what would a debate achieve when
we're just two weeks away from having a
new prime minister announced and they
will have a plan of their own
what it would achieve would it be to
pass a law it wouldn't be just so that
we could discuss it it would be so that
we can pass the legislation that would
be necessary for us to override the
price rise uh the rise in the price cap
that off gen will be announcing in seven
days time that could happen next week if
we get back to parliament on monday that
is up to the government to request the
speaker and they can do that the prime
minister is perfectly capable of opening
his email which i sent to him last night
asking him to do just this i've also
asked both leadership candidates to back
that call if they're really serious
about helping working people and
struggling households and businesses
through this crisis through this cost of
living crisis they should back our call
right now and we should be passing that
legislation next week well yes and
obviously you think it's the best plan
but not everybody else does there are a
lot of people out there that say it's
very expensive and it's only a
short-term fix as soon as you
release that
freeze on price cap inflation will just
shoot up again
well what we're focusing on is what's
going to help people right now and we do
know where we're going to get the money
for that plan and as i said we are going
to concentrate primarily on getting the
money back from the oil and gas
producers who are making massive win for
profits and have been for some time now
that's how we'd pay for it it would help
those people for example those four
million households who are on
pre-payment meters where they have to
feed a meter with cash um and top it up
at the local shop if they run out and
i've watched this happen with struggling
working families who have been put on a
pre-payment meter and they run out of
power because that power costs much more
than it does for those people on bills
and direct debits now we would fix that
gap with our plan and we would also keep
the price cap from rising so that would
save most households around a thousand
pounds now yes we'll need a long-term
plan as well labour does have a
long-term plan and i would like us to
get into government sooner rather than
later so we can insulate homes invest in
renewable energy protect our energy
security and conduct that green energy
sprint that this country and our planet
so badly needs but right now we have to
focus on what's in front of people right
now and their worries for how they're
going to get through the winter whether
or not they're going to be able to
afford to heat and eat and that's the
start choice we're facing and the
government needs to do the right thing
get us back to parliament and legislate
him
we're in the midst of uh rail strikes
once again are you happy with kirsten's
stance on this discouraging uh members
from going to the picket lines
does that is are you on the side of
working people in labour anymore of
course we're on the side of working
people labor believes in the right to
strike and we also know that
constituency mps should and do always
listen to the needs and views of our
constituents and we do my job as a
member of kier's shadow cabinet is to
prepare to get us into government so
that we can pass in the first 100 days
that employment bill that workers rights
chartered that would so benefit people
who are right now calling out for help
and understandably so that's our role in
the labour movement that employment bill
is something that angela rainer has
worked on with the trade unions and it
would protect the right to bargain and
protect the right to fair pay it would
end the unfair practices of foreign
damaging people's lives very briefly
you're about to fall off air would you
go on a picket line or not
that's not my role my role is actually
to listen to my constituents and to work
on the legislation that would help
prevent the need for strikes to take
place in the first place